buon pomeriggio a tutti e grazie a te ed
ex di avermi dato questa occasione di
essere su questo palco oggi perché mi dà
l'opportunità di trasferirvi una
grandissima idea innovativa
oggi infatti vi parlerò della moneta
ecco vedo già delle perplessità qui
adesso i fari sparati ma effettivamente
la prima sly non mi aiuta a tradurre un
po l'innovazione i contenuti innovativi
e di questa immagine
pensavi questa immagine e risale circa
una moneta coniata nel vii secolo avanti
cristo pare la prima in assoluta
l'electro il leader creso ed è l'idea
ebbe l'idea di coniare questo questa
moneta in oro in oro e argento per
facilitare gli scambi quale unità di
conto
per riuscire quindi a dare la stessa
unita alle merci che venivano scambiate
poi venne adottata nelle polis greche
poi divenne la dracma insomma di idee di
successo stiamo parlando per i contenuti
innovativi e ho bisogno magari fare
qualche passo avanti bisogna di una mano
da parte vostra
tutti voi avete delle monete in tasca si
sé tante chi più chi meno giusto ecco da
teme le grazie
se posso no sto scherzando però
ragioniamoci un attimo su una cosa
sapete veramente che cosa avete in tasca
sapete veramente qual è diciamola che
strumento è quello della moneta perché
irata ok è uno strumento di scambio è
una riserva di valore è un unità di
conto come voleva il nostro simpatico
reca reso perché se fosse veramente così
pochi anni fa senza andare millenni fa
pochi anni fa cosa e successo questi
signori qui hanno portato all'asta anche
l'insegna se l'utilizzo smodato degli
strumenti cosiddetti derivati che
avevano creato un euforia enorme nel
mondo economico ci hanno fatto andare a
picco
sono stato utilizzato in maniera
assurdamente speculativa e sulla nostra
pelle ahimè battuta mare abbiamo capito
l'etimologia della parola derivato è
strumento derivato quello che ci ha
portato alla deriva
allora io dico ma tutto questo che è
successo
sono tra l'altro a 2.000 chilometri di
distanza ma cosa c'entra con la nostra
economia locale
cosa c'entra con cosa sempre al fatto
che il giorno dopo che nel crack della
rim ambrosio sono entrati in banca
direttore buongiorno salve ieri ero
venuto per il prestito
guardi purtroppo in effetti ma perché
perché a migliaia di famiglie italiane è
stato negato il credito perché a
migliaia di aziende è stata tolta
liquidità e nome di questa presunta
crisi del sistema di liquidità ma
licenziati posti di lavoro sappiamo
tutti quello che è successo ma se ci
pensiamo bene è un paradosso perché come
se il giorno dopo nessun produttore
locale azienda locale avesse voglia di
produrre ci fossero i magazzini vuoti
nessuno aveva più voglia di comprare ma
non è così è andato in crisi il sistema
di pagamento il mezzo di pagamento non
l'economia locale
allora cosa fare come uscirne
probabilmente se di grande crisi
finanziaria si è trattato lo sappiamo
bene allora pensiamo a una soluzione
finanziaria
pensiamo che esse andato in crisi il
sistema di pagamento con la moneta a
corso legale beh facciamo dotare le
imprese della possibilità di crearsi un
altra moneta questo guardato hanno
pensato quattro ragazzi sardi freschi di
studi universitari e all'estero sono
rientrati nella loro isola qualche anno
fa e hanno sviluppato un'idea
imprenditoriale proprio basandola su
questa hanno fondato il sar decs quindi
l'electro è ripreso laurent fondato il
sad e se sono andata in giro della pena
dire guardate che potete esprimere la
vostra produttività la vostra ricchezza
adottando un altro unità di conto
beh guardate hanno creato un qualcosa la
cui eco è andata ben oltre l'isola ben
oltre anche i confini italiani e poche
settimane fa hanno avuto alcun
riconoscimento ufficiale in un
bellissimo articolo sul financial times
eccolo qua cesar decs factor
cosa hanno pensato questi ragazzi han
pensato che ieri quando è uscito dalla
banca mi scusino il signore in sala
ancorché particolarmente incazzato col
direttore però magari continuava aver
fame e nel centro di bologna poteva
continuare a trovare dei ristoratori che
avrebbero cucinato
per lui probabilmente sì il problema era
il sistema di pagamento ma se ci
accorgevamo su qualcosa di diverso
poteva funzionare benissimo hanno messo
a terra e secondo me questa è la forza
di un'idea innovativa e se in grado di
metterla a terra a favore dell'economia
locale
la famosa stanza di compensazione cos'è
la stanza di compensazione ma guarda te
è molto semplice perché vedete c'è un
operatore a che probabilmente ha un
debito con un operatore b che
probabilmente un debito con l'operatore
c e così via ma avete capito sono
finisce il countdown
ecco allora la cosa più ragionevole e
non è tanto costringere tutti questi
operatori a pagare i propri debiti in
euro che non hanno perché se crisi di
liquidità o fallire cari in banca a
chiedere prestiti che le banche non
vogliono dare perché c'è crisi di
liquidità la cosa più ragionevole sembra
può apparire compensare le partite di
debito e di credito il più possibile fra
di loro così facendo riducendo il
bisogno complessivo di liquidità
semplice no due presupposti fondamentali
primo lavorare sulla produttività locale
delle aziende quindi se il cosiddetto
potenziale inespresso ovverosia i posti
vuoti di un ristorante così che eri
contento
le camere vuote di un albergo le ore
buche di un professionista i magazzini
che non cercano tutto ciò che il sistema
in euro il mercato in euro non riesce a
far distribuire si può distribuire
adottando questa nuova unità di conto e
creando questa possibilità di economia
condivisa si dice anche secondo
presupposto fondamentale è il titolo di
questo intervento che voi ricorderete
sicuramente vero no cioè è la moneta
della fiducia
cos'è la moneta della fiducia cos'è la
fiducia in questo con nuovo contesto
economico significa che i operatore ho
fiducia che tu che entra nel mio negozio
compri dei miei beni non mi paghi in
euro ma mi dai la possibilità di
accumulare dei crediti che ho fiducia di
poter poi spendere nello stesso mercato
nello stesso circuito perché vero
trattato con lo stesso modo che io sto
trattando te adesso succede una cosa
straordinaria sapete in questi mercati
succede che gli operatori economici del
territorio si collegano tra di loro e
ancorano la loro produce
a livello locale succede quindi che il
ristoratore all'albergatore il meccanico
il gommista sfruttando la loro
potenzialità e produttiva e quindi loro
potenziale inespresso fanno vendite
aggiuntive che diversamente non
avrebbero fatto con la moneta di corso
lega accumulano crediti che poi possono
spendere come beh semplicemente
acquistando beni e servizi che li
servono e quindi risparmiando loro volta
euro o magari facendo investimenti che
tipicamente in in situazioni di crisi
non vengono fatti che sono magari market
di comunicazione pubblicità vi voglio
fare un esempio
un esempio su questo molto vicino a noi
perché cybex hanno declinato questo loro
nuovo modello economica anche su altre
regioni italiane quindi circuito liberec
spunto net come diceva danilo è nato un
anno fa in a bologna e e circuito
dell'emilia romagna va benissimo se vuoi
da suscita da qua ha fatto un chilometro
per andare in centro in via mascarella
c'è un cinema che notano i bolognesi
cinema o da il circuito cinema bologna
ha partecipato al circuito libera e se
sono otto sale cinematografiche e si è
messo d'accordo con altri otto dieci
operatori di circuito le imprese di
realizzare un carosello pubblicitario
insieme troviamo il gommista troviamo il
meccanico troviamo tutti anche operatori
di medie dimensioni e noti in natura si
che nel circuito anziché piscine sogese
accanto del gruppo era anche altre
realizzano questo questo carosello che
andrà in onda in centinaia di spot nei
mesi di programmazione più calda che a
quello invernale simpatica questa cosa
comunque è vero tutti vanno al cinema ci
sono circa potenzialmente 300 mila
biglietti venduti in questo in questo
circuito cinema in questo periodo e
hanno realizzato questa cosa
assolutamente in crediti in liber ex
quindi è molto molto bello e molto
produttivo come funziona questa cosa
funziona molto semplicemente basta basta
abbandonare tutti i concetti sulla
moneta legale quindi noi non ci siamo
messi a bologna nell'osteria stampare
libere nelle banche non li stampano per
noi la moneta di corso legale se già si
chiama euro la conosciamo tutti
un euro equivale a un libere se l'unità
di conto aiuta quindi queste imprese a
farsi credito reciproco tra di loro ma
dico ma esiste una parola che può essere
la guida
ma di una vita intera adesso non voglio
scomodare i dieci comandamenti venga
dato numeri ricordo neanche tutti però
reciprocità di operatore economico mi
comporto come vorrei che tutti
comportarsi con me e quindi ad otto
delle regole comuni molto semplici gli
stessi prezzi che applichi neuro le
applico in liberi tutti i conti partono
partono a zero sono concesse delle
posizioni di debito dove misura in cui
io come azienda riverso dei miei beni e
servizi in credito nel circuito ci sono
anche delle possibilità della luna una
struttura che facilita questi scambi
quindi vedete delle persone che dialogo
nel servizio broker con le persone
dell'azienda per fare acquisti e vendite
esiste un sistema informatico è voluto
che emette dei conti e mette delle carte
le linee di interesse interne circuito
sono sempre zero
guardate interessantissimo è pensare a
una cosa pensare che in questi in queste
in questa nuova economia condivisi in
questo nuovo possibilità di fare
economia
le posizioni di debito non si accumulano
costantemente ma si trovano
costantemente dei creditori che hanno
voglia di acquistare questo perché il
sarde xvi libere come voleva il creso
non sono unità di conto non sono monete
di accumulo speculative creano fanno
girare alla ricchezza fanno girare la
produzione
guardate questo dato misura la velocità
di circolazione della moneta
allora guardate il sarde se prendiamo la
scena più strutturata evidentemente che
ha più al periodo di tempo ne è
consolidato circola 12,28 volte cosa
vuol dire passa di mano in mano 12,28
volte in unità di tempo che un anno la
bce emanato questa questo dato per quel
che riguarda l'euro l'euro circa una
volta e mezzo queste unità di conto
circolano dieci volte di più della
moneta a corso legale ma pensate quanta
produttività in più quanta ricchezza in
più se è vero come è vero che la moneta
misura il valore dei beni che vengono
commercializzati ben misurerà tanto più
valore
quanto più velocemente questi beni
vengono vengono transati quindi proprio
questa unità di conto come voleva il re
creso e ci sono anche già delle
applicazioni molto interessante sapete
quanti pò welfare aziendale cosa
intendiamo sono state aperte
centinaia di conti cosiddetti bitri ai
dipendenti delle imprese aderenti
quindi questo significa che il
dipendente ha potuto ottenere in crediti
ciò che in euro magari ora sembra faceva
fatica a ottenere quindi stiamo parlando
della diciamo del premio del benefit del
prestito
uno degli esempi più evocativi in
sardegna si raccontano di un matrimonio
fatto in crediti quindi ristoratore qui
in emilia replicheremo con un divorzio
fatto in crediti visti gli ultimi dati
che ci sono a parte la battuta comunque
voglio dire questo è veramente
importante questa economia condiviso
circolare come viene chiamata solo per
darvi l'entità di questo fenomeno e ho
finito il mio tempo vi vi dico due
numeri perché questi sostanza no poi in
pochi anni guardate sarde che cosa
transato a oltre 3.000 aziende iscritte
oltre 1500 conti famosi between che vi
dicevo prima dei dipendenti oltre 63
milioni di transato più di 90 mila
operazioni effettuate
però nel nostro piccolo diciamo così
circuito liberi si difende molto bene
anzi ha ottenuto dei risultati secondo
noi da un anno di tempo a questa parte
ancora più importanti in un anno di
tempo in un'azienda in start up 130
aziende hanno aderito vi sono già
presenti nel circuito 50 settori
merceologici
e proprio la scorsa settimana abbiamo
superato i 500 mila euro di transato
quindi quasi mille operazioni effettuate
se non ce la facevamo avevamo già deciso
di chiede andrea paure di spostare di
una settimana the dexter green questo
dato va assolutamente pubblicato
beh signore allora vi lascio con un
intimissima considerazione nel merito e
riprendendo la home page ricevuto
liberec spunto net e l'intera regione in
rete io da un pò di anni da un po di
tempo che mi sto occupando di questa
cosa e devo dire che è bella etica ma si
fa ci sono le difficoltà dello start up
naturale ci sono difficoltà ascoltavo
prima gli altri relatori no di uscire
dalla propria area di confort vi rubo un
minuto in più ma questa ve la devo
raccontare quindi soprattutto gli usa
mettono dai non dirla questa la dico
perché mi riguarda allora ieri a fine
giugno vanno
un ristorante del centro insieme a un
dirigente di circuito libera se altri
due collaboratori per fare una pausa
pranzo di lavoro
questo ristorante aderito noi facciamo
una pausa di lavoro il titolare si siede
con noi per il caffè perché parliamo di
vari eventi che si possono realizzare in
questo modo mi alzo va dalla cassa e
pago in euro è tremenda questa cosa qua
se proprio l'abitudine che noi abbiamo
consolidato ma se scontate anche i
ragazzi sardi vi racconteranno c'è sul
sito le difficoltà iniziali dei facciate
che hanno preso però poi sono riusciti
nei numeri concreti a ottenere quello
che hanno tenuto e soprattutto
personalmente gli sarò sempre grato
perché mi hanno dimostrato una cosa
molto importante molto vera vedete
dietro queste 90 mila transazioni
effettuate queste migliaia di di
possibilita in piu e ci sono delle
strette di mano quando si conclude un
affare ci si stringe la mano quando un
buon a farci sensori da sempre
allora mi hanno dimostrato che tutto
sommato il sorriso la stretta di mano la
fiducia le relazioni tra persone valgono
ancora di più oggi di qualsiasi modello
economico o qualsiasi sistema di credito
qualcuno si voglia inventare grazie